the um I mean just to just to explain
that by the way I I did a big analysis
of chat GPT and I I was pretty surprised
that that um you know when tragic Beauty
first came out I know that the people
who made it and I said did you know it
was going to work and they said no
that's um and I you know none of us knew
it was going to work if you looked at
its predecessors they didn't work well
and and suddenly charity BTS started
working and I I even wrote um
I wrote a little piece about about how
it works and it even exists now as a
book and it's I just saw this today for
the first time but um Let me let me show
you I wonder if I have some pictures
here well you know the basic strategy of
of you know what chat GPT is doing is
it's taking uh sort of everything a
bunch of a trillion words basically from
the web from a bunch of books things
like that and it's saying given that I
was started with the the words the best
thing about AI is its ability to given
what I saw on the web what's the next
word likely to be that's it that's its
basic strategy and just keeps doing that
word by word it's kind of remarkable
nowadays these things have well it used
to be four thousand it's now more than
that a window of words that it pays
attention to it's generating one word at
a time but yet it manages to maintain
sort of coherence by having a large
window of of words that it can look back
to okay so the question is and so you
can kind of go and see um I've got some
nice pictures perhaps rather
uninteresting that's just how neural
Nets get trained but you can kind of
look inside oh there's a there's a piece
of the brain of Chachi PT it's kind of
fun that's sort of an encoding of a
mixture of human knowledge and human
language somewhere deep inside
um inside the gpt3 I think in this case
um the question is so one question is
what is this doing why does it work one
thing to realize about it is that it is
ultimately a neural net
where everything just flows through from
the beginning to the end once you've
trained a Chachi BT
um it is you're feeding it the words the
feeding it words so far and it is just
Rippling through this big neural net
that happens to have 175 billion weights
in this particular case
um and telling you what the
probabilities for the next word should
be so it's doing in a sense a very
shallow computation it's doing I think
it's a
um a few hundred layers deep
um and but it's just like given a word
it's going to Ripple through and figure
out probabilities for next words
um and uh
the um uh and the thing to realize that
it's not doing is that irreducible
computation that I talked about it's
just Rippling through and saying what's
the next word going to be and it it the
only way that it gets to do a
non-trivial computation it can actually
do Universal computation in principle is
by looking you kind of get to see all
the steps that it shows because every
word every time it generates a new word
it looks at all the words it's generated
before and that's its only way of kind
of having a recursive uh process of
doing things but in any case as as the
thing that
it ends up being a rather shallow
computation
um relative to the kinds of things that
we see in typical irreducible
computations even in various cases a
very simple program so there's a
difference between what we see for
example in nature where we see many
irreducible computations happen that go
for a long way and what we see in
something like chat GPT and the thing to
to realize if we ask well why does chat
gbt actually work I think the answer is
that it's something that Aristotle might
have got to but didn't quite get there
and it's the following thing so people
are sort of find it remarkable that chat
GPD can do logic well how did Aristotle
come up with logic well he looked at a
bunch of I mean we don't know really but
a sort of a model for it would be looked
at a bunch of examples of rhetoric a
bunch of arguments that people have made
and said oh there are these patterns and
the arguments people made those patterns
are syllogistic logic those are these
particular forms of syllogism that where
one thing is deduced from another and
that's what gbt is seeing in in lots of
the text that it finds on the web it's
seeing essentially syllogisms because it
sees when you get this and this and this
it gives this
um and so
the uh so it sort of discovers the
logistic logic
covers more than syllogistic logic it
discovers in a sense what one might call
a semantic grammar of language I think
so in language we're used to the idea
that there is a syntactic grammar a
grammar where for example we know that
nouns and verbs go together in certain
ways we know different parts of speech
match up in certain ways but we don't
have a similar kind of thing that goes
at a more semantic level of asking what
are the ways in which uh you know what
how do you put together words in ways
that make make some sense
making sense is different from actually
being realized in the world but at least
makes sense so to speak and you know
there were lots of experiments that were
done in the 1600s actually on so-called
philosophical languages some more recent
work that's been done I've long been
interested in the question of whether
one I mean in a sense are well from
language computational language is for a
large number of domains a language that
gives you this kind of semantic grammar
a language that allows you to specify
meaningful things about lots of kinds of
domains doesn't cover all domains it
doesn't cover a lot of domains of
typical everyday human discourse it
covers domains that are relevant for for
understanding things like the natural
world but any case that that um that's
the
uh the the the kind of I think the
reason that chat GPT can work is that we
humans are making use of some
essentially a semantic grammar that is a
sense a a further version of logic
um that uh uh that it's managed to piece
together so to speak and there's
probably a much more efficient way of
doing what it does by just directly
using that kind of symbolic semantic uh
grammar but anyway so by the way a thing
that um uh We've um uh I wrote something
about and maybe you'll see some more
about in in due courses is once you have
something like charge apt that is
dealing with human language it becomes
kind of a a way of of being a linguistic
interface to things in the world so you
might just have a set of bullet points
about oh I want to say this and this and
this okay you tell it make make a whole
essay about that and it can do that but
you know what it's doing is is
constructing text that is kind of you
know text that is kind of like what you
would expect it to be based on the text
that it read from the web it can't do
this sort of irreducible computations
but if it could use tools like we humans
use tools then it could do those things
if for example it could call wolfen
Alpha which conveniently happens to have
a natural language interface then it
would be able to ask things and actually
do those computations so maybe something
that you can you can find something I
wrote about this in January and maybe
maybe more will happen along those lines
in the rather near future but I'll I'll
just mention one thing maybe which is
kind of thinking about what is the world
like when the world is run by AIS
and what what is that what does it feel
like to be in a world that's that's run
by AI so you know much of what the AIS
do is things which will not be
comprehensible to us and we can expect
so in a sense there's all this
computation going on and it's
computation that we can we
essentially the point is that once we
have a situation where kind of the the
there are AIS everywhere so to speak it
is very similar to the situation that we
already have with nature nature is
already running all these computations
We Exist around nature so to speak and
the we we have found ways to uh there's
there's also more to say about this kind
of Observer Theory business and how that
relates to the way we perceive nature
and the way we perceive kind of the
civilization of of the AIS but I suppose
the the um the thing that perhaps is a
is a useful place to end perhaps is is
uh it's the beginning of the thing I
wrote yesterday but but anyway is this
is this idea that um uh you know when
when the world is full of AI computation
it is in a sense nothing new because the
world is already full of computation in
nature and the question of then how we
enter interact with those AIS that
happen to be things that we constructed
is a different question that I tried to
address a bit in the thing I wrote
yesterday all right I should stop there
thanks
you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy